[Música]
el presidente de Estados Unidos Joe
biden aseguró haber tomado ya la
decisión de postularse para un segundo
mandato al terminar su gira por Irlanda
y sin dar más detalles el jefe de la
Casa Blanca dijo que anunciaría su
campaña relativamente pronto
la inflación de tres dígitos en
Argentina no ha llegado a su pico en
marzo los precios subieron 104,3%
interanual casi dos puntos más de lo
registrado en febrero educación prendas
de vestir y alimentos lo que más sube
en Cuba escasean los combustibles Desde
hace dos semanas se observan largas
filas en las estaciones de servicio el
gobierno atribuye la situación a la
reducción del suministro por parte de
sus proveedores entre los que se
incluyen Venezuela y Rusia
Sean bienvenidos a esta emisión de
noticias en las que destacamos las
noticias más importantes del continente
americano
comenzamos con en Estados Unidos porque
el presidente Joe biden dijo que ya tomó
la decisión de postularse para un
segundo mandato y que anunciaría su
campaña relativamente pronto lo hizo al
terminar su visita oficial a Irlanda en
donde miles de personas lo ovacionaron
mientras de vuelta a casa sus índices de
popularidades están entre los más bajos
desde que comenzó su mandato el jefe de
la Casa Blanca ha mostrado durante mucho
tiempo su intención de lanzarse a la
reelección en unas elecciones en las que
enfrentaría en las urnas al expresidente
de republicano Donald Trump
puede decirnos en los últimos días ha
cambiado su cálculo sobre cuándo hará un
anuncio sobre su plan para campaña
presidencial no no no no ya hice ese
cálculo lo anunciaremos relativamente
pronto pero el viaje aquí reforzó mi
sentido de optimismo sobre lo que se
puede hacer
así que ha tomado una decisión sólo
tiene que anunciarla te lo dije mi plan
es volver a postularme
también se pronunció sobre el escándalo
de filtraciones de los documentos
clasificados del pentágono que han
dejado a Estados Unidos en medio de una
tormenta diplomática el mandatario
aseguró que pidió a su gobierno
averiguar por qué el sospechoso de
publicar los documentos tuvo acceso a
tanta información
Se irá compareció por primera vez ante
un tribunal Federal fue imputado por dos
delitos de los que se declaró No
culpable el informe desde Samuel Salgado
sospechoso de ocasionar el peor
escándalo de la última década en materia
de filtraciones de documentos secretos
en Estados Unidos compareció por primera
vez ante un tribunal de Boston
texeira Fue capturado por el FBI y el
jueves y es acusado de retención y
transmisión no autorizada de información
de defensa nacional en virtud de la ley
de espionaje tanto el departamento de
Justicia como el pentágono son enfáticos
en señalar la gravedad del escándalo de
filtración
no se trata solo de llevarse documentos
a casa eso es por supuesto ilegal en sí
mismo se trata de la transmisión tanto
de la retención ilegal como de la
transmisión de los documentos todo el
mundo sabe aquí que los documentos al
final fueron transmitidos
este fue un acto criminal deliberado es
una violación de las pautas creo que es
importante entenderlo
jacqueta un joven empleado de la guardia
Nacional de las fuerzas aéreas Se
declaró No culpable pero permanecerá
bajo arresto en la espera de juicio la
audiencia de tensión está prevista para
el 19 de abril si es hallado culpable
podría enfrentar 15 años de prisión los
documentos filtrados Aparentemente por
teixeira se cuentan en más de 100 y
revelan principalmente información
estratégica sobre la guerra en Ucrania
también evidencian espionaje
estadounidense algunos de sus
importantes aliados como Corea del Sur y
circularon en redes sociales durante
varios días antes de que las autoridades
estadounidenses se percataran
y en ese mismo país la Corte Suprema
mantiene temporalmente el acceso sin
restricciones a la píldora abortiva
myfer pristona la decisión llega tras
las restricciones impuestas previamente
por una corte de apelaciones que iban a
entrar en vigencia el fin de semana los
detalles de la noticia con nuestro
corresponsal en Washington Cristóbal
Vázquez
la Corte Suprema de Justicia restauró
temporalmente el acceso total a la
píldora abortiva Mr pistone suspendiendo
la decisión de un tribunal inferior de
Texas que dejaba sin piso la aprobación
del gobierno de la píldora abortiva
utilizada en más de la mitad de los
abortos en Estados Unidos El juez Samuel
alito accedió a la solicitud del
gobierno de restaurar hasta el miércoles
de la próxima semana el acceso total a
la píldora y solicitó además información
adicional para el próximo martes
concretamente el gobierno de biden y El
fabricante de medicamentos danco
laboratoris instaron a la corte a no
cuestionar la experiencia de la
administración de drogas y alimentos de
Estados Unidos fda que se basó en datos
de docenas de ensayos clínicos cuando
aprobó la mifepristone hace 23 años y
que ahora un juez nombrado por Trump
está cuestionando según el gobierno
dejar el fallo del juez de Texas en su
lugar crearía confusión incertidumbre
para los proveedores de servicios de
aborto y tendría consecuencias
devastadoras para la capacidad de la
industria farmacéutica y para que esta
industria pueda llevar nuevos
medicamentos al mercado la Corte Suprema
también podría reprogramar rápidamente
una sesión informativa completa y un
argumento oral para revisar el caso
antes del receso de verano de la corte
el presidente de Colombia Gustavo Petro
será recibido en Washington la próxima
semana por su homólogo estadounidense
Joe biden la visita del que ha sido
destacado por la casa blanca como un
socio clave se llevará a cabo el próximo
jueves y tiene como objetivo reforzar
lazos económicos y de seguridad según el
jefe de estado colombiano la lucha
contra el narcotráfico estará en la
agenda sin embargo Petro ha tildado de
fracaso la guerra contra las drogas por
lo que ha pedido un nuevo enfoque
internacional
y en Argentina el Instituto Nacional de
estadísticas y censos dio a conocer que
en marzo los ciudadanos experimentaron
una inflación del
104,3% interanual este hecho aumenta el
descontento ante la gestión del
presidente Alberto Fernández de Cara a
las elecciones presidenciales del
próximo 22 de octubre
es el azote de la economía Argentina en
el mes de marzo la nación suramericana
registró la inflación más alta de los
últimos 12 meses según el Instituto
Nacional de estadísticas y censo indec
el aumento de los precios a los
consumidores se ubicó en un ciento
cuatro coma tres por ciento este
fenómeno económico al que el estado no
ha sabido dar respuesta golpea
constantemente el bolsillo de los
argentinos puedo hacerlo a las compras
de supermercado y semanalmente me van
aumentando las cosas semanalmente es
decir y en una proporción a veces en los
alimentos del 10 y 15% caso del queso
Pues sería la carne la carne me pasó en
un año de mil 1200 pesos a 2800 cerca
del 40% de los ciudadanos vive la
pobreza según el indec Un aumento que se
ha vivido en los últimos años en parte
bajo el gobierno peronista tratando de
pensar que en algún momento vamos a
poder estar mejor tenemos un país como
para poder estar mejor pero bueno
Lamentablemente nos administran de una
manera muy mala la nación suramericana
también vive una de las peores sequías
de su historia lo que la imposibilita
exportar miles de millones de dólares en
productos agrícolas esto además
incrementa el valor de granos como el
trigo y el maíz dentro de sus fronteras
yo creo que en primera instancia lo que
bajas lo que bajas es la calidad del
producto sí porque lo que antes capaz
consumías de un poco mejor hoy está como
si siempre fue claro siempre fue cinco
no sé 10 pesos más hoy son 100 pesos más
y en el global al cierre que vos haces
la compra del mes es como su montones
mucha la diferencia la inflación hace
Mella en la popularidad del presidente
Alberto Fernández de cara las próximas
elecciones presidenciales de octubre
según la agencia de noticias un poco más
del 20% de los argentinos aprueba su
gestión donde la economía y los
enfrentamientos internos en el peronismo
han sido
su punto más débil
[Música]
y el presidente cubano Miguel Díaz
canela atribuyó la crisis de
combustibles por la que atraviesa su
país al incumplimiento de suministro por
parte de sus aliados Desde hace dos
semanas se observan largas filas en las
estaciones de servicio Cuba importa casi
todo el combustible que consume y lo usa
principalmente para generar energía
Venezuela y Rusia son dos de los
principales suministradores de petróleo
pero con la crisis se redujo la cantidad
enviada
los países que tienen con nosotros
determinados compromisos para
suministrarnos gasolina a partir de los
convenios que tenemos han estado también
una situación energética compleja y no
han podido cumplir esos compromisos y
eso ha llevado o ha propiciado ha
ocasionado que de un consumo entre
quinientas y seiscientas toneladas
diarias de gasolina
que el país
consume diariamente en estos momentos
estamos con coberturas de menos de
cuatrocientas toneladas diarias de
gasolina para todas las actividades del
país de manera diaria finalizamos este
informativo quédense con nosotros
[Música]